[Music]
jody is in dayton ohio hi jody how are
you
uh better than i deserve dave um thanks
for taking my call sure what's up i have
a little bit of a question going through
a disillusion or divorce basically and
it's kind of left me in a financial ruin
i feel like um
was with the guy for 16 years and
cheated on me and it's been really
devastating and i had like a really good
financial goal to be debt-free in like
seven years you know
start my family
um
it's just not worked out that way and so
what i'm looking at is i make 73 a year
i have a 401k of 55 000.
i've got quite a bit of cash on hand
liquid cash would be about 46 000 which
i was probably either going to pay off
my student debt which is
38 000
or you know pay off part of it and maybe
invest and hope that in a few years that
investment grows and i can just really
tackle down for debt with that
my
house right now the appraisal on it was
625 000.
and i owe 189 on it
but with the payout to my husband after
this disillusion i'll be paying him out
about 95 000.
i'm kind of left with
i think
let's see here
a 322 000 loan now on the house by
myself making 73 000 a year my payment
um if i consolidate like my college into
my house
and kind of just sit on that because
it's been so much of a change i feel
like i might have to go to a mental
hospital basically like it's just so
much i we actually built this house last
year we finished this movement
[Music]
with the dream house you know to raise
the family in with him
but i just you know my payments looking
at like 1900 to possibly 20
22 or 2100 at the max is what the bank
is telling me
how old are you
what'd you say how old are you
i'm gonna be 32 on december
first i'm so sorry
yeah thanks thank you
you're not gonna like me but i'm gonna
love you well okay
yeah sell the house
okay
you know why
well i'd not have the stress of the
financial debt i'm sure you get to start
fresh with a clean white board
you don't walk in there every day
looking at a custom-made home that was a
dream home that you built with a guy who
committed adultery on you
yeah
your heart's broken and every time you
walk in the living room it's going to
break again
and you're paying a huge payment for the
privilege
and
i mean the best way to start fresh after
a broken heart is start fresh
okay
and it's just i'm just cleaning i just
want to clean i just want your life to
be clean and simple to give you a place
where you can heal from this because
this has been really hard for you
and what what kind of time frame should
i be looking at to make this transition
because it's like
right now
i i just don't know like with so many
changes i had to get the vaccine so i
didn't lose my job you know
um
so i did that but it's just like i just
i feel like if i have like one more
major change
yeah i what i would do is just try to
get life as simple as i can
until you start breathing again
right now you're not taking deep breaths
you're just kind of
you got the stress on it's like somebody
standing on your chest
and um that just makes you human you
just have this huge horrible thing
you're going through
and it's just real and and what our
friend dr john deloney would call trauma
and it really really is and so give
yourself some space if it takes you a
year to do nothing and make make out a
life that makes you boring and bored
and then you can just sit and
heal and give yourself some room without
push and pull without
striving towards some goal
or something so you're a pretty
goal-oriented person you like to have a
plan and execute the plan so you're
gonna wander your way back to that
pretty quick as soon as your psyche is
healed enough to allow you to do that
but give yourself a little room to cry
is that okay
yeah i think i mean it is kind of my
plan to i'm probably yeah 15 acres for
just myself it was never meant to be
just for me it actually made me quite
angry um there you go got some in that
phase of of grief right now but yeah i'm
just showing i'm like well if i meet
somebody soon yeah but you don't want to
live there with somebody and you're not
going to meet me right
it's too soon
it's too soon right now you're still
just you're still just your head's
spinning oh
so give yourself a little
and and get rid of him out of the
picture because that's what i need to do
but then he needs to go away he'll kind
of keep the house for a handful of
months or just listen on the market
right now i'll put it on the market
right now i wouldn't go refinance it i
wouldn't go the expense of refinancing
it he can wait to get paid out when the
house sells and guess what it'll sell in
20 minutes
if
if i uh go ahead and refinance it he's
agreed to take 90 but if i
just sell it then he'll try and take
half of the equity because he would be
owed that
um well i think this is a negotiation
with a philanderer
i think this is a negotiation with a
philanderer
i think you punch his lights out and get
him to take 90 and you sell the house
absolutely right he deserves nothing
hold his feet to the lawyer would say
otherwise i don't give a crap what his
lawyer says this is a negotiation
everything's a negotiation you want your
90 i'm putting the house on the market
you're going to get your 90. as you're
going to get it as soon as you would if
i refinance it i'm not going to go to
the refinance cost you're going to take
your 90. you're going to walk away with
your girlfriend and you're going to kiss
my butt
and this is the negotiation
i hope your lawyers mean
oh she is good yeah
yeah i don't have it in me right now i
usually can be but i don't have it well
i don't want you to have to fight it
tell your lawyer to go sick them skid
them yeah yeah and if you have to
refinance it to cut it way down if you
lose the negotiation fine go do it but
you're just losing the refinance costs
because you're going to turn around pay
the stupid mortgage off in 30 days
anyway because you're putting house on
the market now
right now it just seems like a lot to
try and because it will sell i would say
in a couple three months max because it
is a high amount and a big portion of
land which a lot of people don't want to
take care of but no it's it's a premium
real estate market it's gonna sell
it's gonna sell in 20 minutes
like do it that quickly because it's
like
you know um
divorce
clean up your life
clean up your life as soon as you can
as quickly as you can simplify
everything and give yourself some room
to grieve
that this guy did you and he mis
mistreated you
i'm so sorry